well i think if you just watch mac play
throughout the course of the year if it
came to mental errors he only made a few
uh he did he was always very well
prepared i think stark did a great job
with him
but he was always very well prepared
you know for every game but he he went
out there and sort of you know calmly
just executed and took what the defense
gave him and made the right choices and
decisions based on what we had coached
them to do
seldom did he force the ball seldom that
he turn it over
really managed exactly what we expected
him to manage and i know that when you
say a guy does that everybody thinks
he's not a very good player
he's not capable of anything else but
managing but to me to be a good
quarterback you got to be a good manager
then your ability to make plays sort of
you know goes from there and mack has
ability to make plays because he's smart
he's accurate he's going to throw the
ball in the right place and
he's going to always help the offensive
team be in the right situation
whether it's a run or a pass or whatever
so
he is really really smart but he's
always really well prepared i but
i think he analyzes what's going to
happen
before it happens
in terms of what the expectation is
for him on that particular play and he
has a good visualization of what our
players are doing and how the defense is
going to react to it relative to what
they do and i think that's what helps
his decision-making process
so that he makes good choices and
decisions
on one hand you can say well nick saban
is going to boost his guys but spot the
lie is there anything that he said no it
is inaccurate right and i think he
prides himself on not
overselling his writers because his
credibility's on the line but when you
have great players you don't have to
oversell no you don't have to oversell
but we we've heard him not give like the
most like glowing scouting reports
before you know we've even seen on that
little thing you know what was that
thing with him and bill belichick i mean
he was he was honest with bill about who
the best player here was and you know
this guy needs to do this and whatever
that way so you're right you know his
butt's on the line as far as his
credibility is concerned too yeah and
you know hey i hear that phrase with mac
jones manager whatever and mac i mean uh
and
nick explained it right
he's a manager
with what they asked him to do
but within that too hey some of those
plays hey yeah we want you to do this
here's you know three guys going down
the field okay three guys are covered
hey but there's a spot and you could put
the ball in in here and it's a tight
window and mac jones just always makes
the appropriate throw the appropriate
play the appropriate the appropriate
movement in the pocket you know and
that's where i came away just with you
know when i came away evaluating i just
went man it's just one perfect decision
one perfect throw wait everybody's
covered wow and that's where i ended up
going this guy's a top 10 pick you know
you say what you want about his body or
anything like that and then like i've
said you've heard me say to mike yeah
managing the offense but
the offense was more aggressive this
year than within tua so that tells you
what they thought of mac jones 2. they
thought he was capable
maybe mentally but certainly physically
more than two as far as the degree of
difficulty of drop back passes they
asked him to make compared to 202. that
jumped off to me as well and those are
little context clues i look i like to
look at when i evaluate players because
it tells you what the coaches think of
that guy too
back to the point of
candor from college football coaches
this is a quote from saban from the
belichick and saban documentary on hbo
from a couple of years ago one thing
that you belichick do that a lot of nfl
guys don't do i don't know that you've
ever picked one of our guys if you never
talk to me before picking him and
there's a few other guys in the league
that do that but then there's another 30
teams that i never hear from them and
they pick somebody and i'm saying they
picked that guy right so yeah called
nick saban and i'm sure some of them are
afraid to
but
he he i think
is willing to be candid and blunt and
honest because
those guys are a reflection on him
ultimately his coaching or his failure
as a coach and he's going to promote the
guys that he think are going to make the
program look good right at the next
level every time you send a guy from a
major college program to the nfl and
ends up being a bust that does diminish
to a certain extent the program he comes
from so he's got every reason to do that
and you know what if you're the player
and you want more praise from your coach
when you're heading to the draft earn it
while you're there it's that simple
chris yeah no you're right you earn it
while you're there you know and then
listen i don't know are we going to talk
about devonte smith but i know he makes
some comments about him and everything
that goes along with that too you know
just waxes poetically about the player
and what he brings to the table and
everything like that you know i just i
respect nick saban and how he talks
about his team as players and if you
really listen to him he kind of without
maybe sometimes just coming out with the
flat out truth he he's telling you what
he really thinks of these guys uh and
and that's where i always like listening
to his evaluations of his own team or
players that he's got on the roster
and he did address devonta smith and it
was very glowing it was very positive
and it was intended to push back against
the idea because he's only 170 pounds
right he can't play at the next level
sabin is convinced that he can and again
saban isn't going to sell a guy that's
going to make him look bad that's going
to make him look like a liar that's
going to make him look like he doesn't
know what he's talking about he's never
going to coach at the nfl level so the
only way he has any credibility at the
nfl level is to be accurate when he says
these are the guys that are good and if
you want to talk about the guys who i
don't believe in give me a phone call
and i'm surprised more of you don't give
me a phone call it's that simple
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports